haha the Joe Rogan experience what's
your regimen for exercising during the
same as usual same as usual yeah yeah
except you can't go to yoga classes but
I'm working out here yeah you know no
workout at my house and I still run the
hills with the dog I've been doing that
a lot more hiking and running I had a
little bit of a knee injury from skiing
mm-hmm but that's healed up but it's um
you know it's not that big a deal for me
luckily I'm fortunately I got a home gym
but there's plenty of videos if you
don't online if you can get any one
thing one piece of equipment that I
would think you would need get a chin-up
bar everything else you could do with
your body weight if you just write out a
bodyweight workout so chin-ups add
chin-ups different kinds of push-ups
like Hindu push-ups Hindu push-ups or
your ass goes up in the air and you bomb
dive oh yeah shop it was like an up dog
yeah exactly those are great those are
great do series of you know sets of 20
of those do regular push-ups do Diamond
push-ups you know with your hands like
this you could do wall presses where
like you do you put your feet on the
wall and you could do like shoulder
presses that way where you're pushing
things overhead you buddy mean like a
handstand
mm-hmm yeah and you just put your feet
on the wall so you rest your feet on the
wall and you just do shoulder presses
yeah instead of pushing weight off over
overhead you just push your whole body
up right so you could do that you can
you can without even leaving your house
you can get crazy cardio workouts just
by doing lunges and switching steps and
doing what are called Hindu squats and
Hindu squats you go down they're all
just all body weight no wait no added
weight at all you go down and as you go
down when your knees go all the way bent
you actually lift your heels up off the
ground you go on the balls of your feet
and then you put your hands behind you
and then you stand up like this and then
you go back down again in the same thing
you just keep going over and over and
over again and you could do sets of like
a hundred so it's really pretty easy for
the first ten and then for the first
fifteen and twenty and then you go okay
oh this gonna be 30 whoo this is some
work fifty holy [ __ ] I'm halfway there
67 you get to a hundred Hindu squats and
your thighs are
[ __ ] burning burning yeah you want to
build up like some wrestlers would they
would do them every day they would do
like 500 Hindu squats every morning
oh [ __ ] yeah it's part of their
conditioning regimen you know the missus
that guy on the WWE now who's on fear
factor once and the most fit guy we ever
had on fear factor by far like you do
freaky [ __ ] like swam and cold water
holding his breath while doing tasks for
like two and a half minutes didn't have
to come up for air where everybody else
would have tapped out a long time ago I
was like this [ __ ] dude is fit and
this is before he was like a superstar
in wrestling like people knew of them he
had been on some reality show he was on
the real world yeah but like super fit
like crazy shape and he was talking
about the different things that he would
do for wrestling and one of the things
was the air squats they would do those
kind of Hindu squats very similar kind
of squats we do 500 a day Wow I was like
god damn and knowing how hard this do
100 you're doing 500 of those a day
that's a punishing workout on your legs
you know if you go anywhere yeah right
from your house we get some of those
rubber bands those rubber bands are
really good - great - those are great
there's a ton of exercises that you can
learn on on Instagram and on YouTube in
particular a bunch of different websites
a bunch of different people that could
show you extras on the onit website we
got a bunch of different workouts
bodyweight workouts and also if you want
to get a kettlebell just get one [ __ ]
kettlebell there's a ton of YouTube
videos it'll give you an amazing workout
with one kettlebell one kettlebell 135
pound kettlebell and these these like
this series of high intensity workouts
from a bunch of different strucked no
[ __ ] there's so much ya meant free coz
there they just want you to tune in to
their contents and they'll give you
certain exercises you can do and they
put them in order and they're trying to
build up their Instagram pages or build
up to use two YouTube pages so plenty of
free information get on amazon.com have
them send a 35 Bell to your house one
kettlebell and you placed your gym yeah
one kettlebell one chin up bar you
replaced your gym right I mean every day
you can get a [ __ ] ferocious workout
in a bunch of different ways so the chin
up bar is just for pull-ups and chin-ups
just pull-ups and I guess abs yeah stuff
too you want to get the kind in my
my humble opinion get the kind of screws
into the door I don't trust those ones
that hook I just like I could just see
[ __ ] going wrong right you know I mean I
want a [ __ ] that's not coming
out of the door yeah just this in there
and then from that you could do those
leg races where you hang and you bring
your feet up and touch the bar and then
slowly bring them down to feed open
touch the bar brutal ab workout there's
a ton of [ __ ] you can do from your home
you could do if you want to get in crazy
cardio get these little egg weights they
have a bunch of different sizes and do
rounds of shadow boxing so I have some
that are 5 pounds or 5 pounds in each
hand and you you put on like a timer and
then you just have to shadow box for
three minutes and you're 13 seconds in
you're like oh [ __ ] this
no [ __ ] yeah just keep going keep moving
and it's you can get crazy cardio
without having to go anywhere yeah
anywhere you don't do anything yeah you
know I'm gonna continue with my program
of nothing sleeping with rounds of
furious masturbation furious or do some
push-ups
I've been now I've been doing stuff I've
been family yoga been doing every other
day we found a good video online we do
and then bike rides took a long-ass bike
route my son last night but they closed
the beach they closed the parks yeah the
tennis courts everything
[Applause]